hey I can hear you how you doing my
friend I'm really really good thanks so
much for taking the time to build a call
today I just wanted to just to say
thanks thanks for your support what
you're doing you're killing it
No No thank you very much beyond the
call was expecting well you know what
honestly I just think that in this in
this difficult time
anyone that's making money in property
that's going on that's being positive
you know I want to congratulate those
kinds of people so you said that you've
made more money during lockdown then
previously knew nine-to-five job which
is just incredible yeah yeah definitely
I mean this month as well you know when
I've already made more money and I still
do that you know that's cool that's big
that's called the true definition of an
entrepreneur so part of what's happening
and how you'd be doing that yeah it's
pretty good so basically going on to the
single tree subscribe went through some
of the content and stuff and basically I
started applying applying the videos you
show really helpful as well the ones the
way you started to actually sell deal
and then I basically copied that
Facebook ad and and sent it out so I
grew my messages so I had already
started a little bit then I grew my
restless so now when I found deals
online and it was all over faster so
basically that started talking to loads
of those people you know I think I made
I must have made 20 phone calls over
there over the last three weeks or weeks
or something but most of that has
actually been pretty good I'd like to
say but you know how you were saying in
the in the crash person the DfE you kind
of farmers it's not necessarily hunters
I think that is probably what's what's
been good for me because even though
it's a little slower than maybe what
other people experienced I think I've
built a bit of credibility and rapport
with these people so I know they'll
probably come back because a lot of
times you know oh yeah I don't wanna I
don't really want to be giving you just
got right now I'll see what's going on
I'll wait a few weeks and things
so I think they'll definitely remember
me and come back to its problem sure but
yeah the ones that I managed to get
through have been a big few good deals
actually two of the deals are bought by
the same investor which is quite nice
great great so you've sold what did you
say three deals yeah three deals so two
deals money in the account
all clear the third one that people guys
just having some banking issues so but
he signed all the things and wanted me
to put the official offer for and
everything like that so all that's there
just the money is yet to be pending but
you say you'll sort it out yeah
everything sir and how much you sell
these deals for an average yes so on
average it comes down to about two two
and a half but these three deals that's
been quite different
yeah charge different prices for them to
do I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
yeah tell about the deals and also tell
me how you for how you found the deals
during this really difficult time yeah
sure so the first year sold found on
gumtree
actually this was a guy I spoke to maybe
about a month and a half ago and I saw
his property was online and that's it's
pretty good got all the information and
offered him a pretty decent offer
actually kind of close to his asking
prices and numbers to silhouette and but
he said nope
anyway those final then he called me
back at this time just kind of was
saying about potentially coming back so
he called me said hey you know I
remember you were telling me you wanted
to buy are you still in the market what
what's going on so and the market value
of the property was about 85 and he was
so now we the price I already agree with
him now is seventy thousand so you know
got a pretty good deal also it's already
tenant it and and they're paying market
value rent for it
you just want to get out of the game
grab somebody if they're paying about
five hundred and twenty sounds like a
pretty good deal on these below market
value the return on investments good so
yeah the fact that you've been on the
Samuel 3-6-5 you know how to value a
house you know how to value the market
rent you know how to negotiate a good
deal and in fact you actually if I
remember you sent me some like some
feedback we saw almost some criticisms
of the of the crash course online Jim
did was that was that you yeah yeah yeah
really implemented every one of those
things and there was just some small
some small tweaks he said this could be
a bit better and this was a bit and I
actually I actually took that on bought
and I you know I took it on board and
now the crash course is better as a
result so thanks for the for that for
the detailed feedback and I always I
love to take on feedback I some of the
people you know would probably not think
that because I block haters but there's
a massive difference between a hater and
someone that says hey this is this could
be better or here's some feedback so I
actually really really appreciate that
talked about the process of how you
found the investors I mean you did some
training on that on the Facebook ad side
of things you copied what I did on the
videos talk to me about that yeah so I I
started this sort of sourcing stuff a
little bit a little bit earlier so I
started in January so since then I've
been growing my investors slowly kind of
going through the meetings and thought
about going to Facebook group ever since
you did that video I thought okay well
yeah worst thing that can happen is so
why does I give it a try and actually
works out pretty well I got 77 new
investors in four and a half days how
much did that contact how much the table
cost me it didn't cost me very much
actually it actually cost me $25 because
then I actually my might and area wrong
and it cost me $1 but yeah $25 percent
seven investors and was alright I mean I
think you did you did a lot better but
you know considering nobody really knew
me eight and I didn't really have big
social press or the very good it's very
good going I mean it's a 78 investors
for 25 quid I mean
you only need one of those to buy Dell
off you and and two to three thousand
pounds or in your lap in you've also got
some lease option agreement leads lined
up that you're working on yeah yeah so
this this is actually really good so you
know the motivated sellers video I tried
that and it cost me it ended up costing
me a lot more it cost me about and fifty
quid but I got only six people signing
up to it however each of those six
people have been interested in the in
the news often thing and all of them
have said you know what actually this
sounds like something I'd be interested
in let me have a think about it and and
one of them has actually come back you
know really kind of negotiating it now
on what exactly would be paying up front
and how long exactly the year to be what
exact month it would be so he's in the
conversation with his mortgage lender at
the moment to try and see if he can be
mortgage to get it down and then I'm
mostly parent to work out and then you
know once once he gets a response from
then that's actually a deal in the bag
fantastic and was that fifty pounds per
lead or was for all of those are people
that you're trying to get as lease
options for yourself I imagine yeah so
out of the six one of them is the one
that's super close so I'll be taking on
myself another one is pretty close but
it doesn't really work for me because in
the guys circumstances is slightly
different so I don't know if you saw
that but posted on basically kind of
looking for a little bit of advice on
what how people would receive it but
from that somebody said they wanted to
they wanted to buy it as as I had
already negotiated it pretty good so it
was kind of 10k upfront but that 10k
would come off the purchase price at the
end
yeah but I'm potentially going into the
other agreements now so either that
money to put into those deals
rather than put into this one deal and
be stuck in it sure well will be only
get will be only call again tomorrow on
the Samuel 365 or implement on the group
go which which would be great so I
probably going some details on that how
have you found me have you found
something through these five the
webinars and the calls in the co-chair
video yeah I've actually really enjoyed
it I mean yes it the online course I've
been to I've been to the crash course in
person in January and that's the I kind
of dragged my friend along with me and
then we went it together and that was
actually good there was a lot of stuff
to digest from it so I went through and
started that actually got a started into
actually putting this into action but
then three six five like you know really
goes into quite a lot more detail and
all these kind of burning questions we
had like are you how do we fix this or
what about this incorrect answers all of
them which which we're amazing so yeah I
mean thanks a lot of putting that course
together and these webinars as well has
been been great you and Russell running
it together and I'm I think I've asked a
few questions on there which would be
nonsense that's awesome now it's so good
well honestly I'm so pleased what you
doing I'm so I'm so proud of your
results I know that ones with all the
lockdown stops over and I've no doubt
that you're gonna wind up on winners on
the Wednesday one day not insane and
honestly dude keep up the good work and
I look forward to seeing how you get on
over the coming weeks and months now
definitely I will I'll be killing it and
then you know you'll see me soon
god bless great jobs picture soon yeah
thanks a lot man have a good one bye